[Music]
it was some introduction The Prime Time
curtain razor for a presidential
candidate like no other and he is
currently leading the Republican field
while also facing multiple criminal
investigations and an indictment just
yesterday he was found liable for sexual
abuse and defamation
barely a day ago a jury awarded the
writer E Gene Carroll five million
dollars in Damages deciding Donald Trump
had sexually abused her
I have no idea who the hell she's a
woman you now he was here ridiculing her
on Primetime TV to the Delight of this
audience playing hanky-panky in a
dressing room okay I don't know if he
was married then or not John Johnson I
feel sorry for you John Mr President can
I
[Applause]
CNN for seven years a mostly Republican
audience in New Hampshire made up the
town hall some apparently undecided
voters it was quickly apparent though
that the Donald Trump Campaign Will
Follow a familiar script most people
understand what happened that was a
rigged election claims of election fraud
delivered in the opening seconds and the
lies continued often are you ready can I
talk yeah when he was challenged by host
Caitlin Collins this time-worn reaction
it's very simple that you're a nasty
person I'll tell you
this though was a new insight asked
repeatedly if he supported Ukraine Trump
refused to answer can you say if you
want Ukraine or Russia to win this War I
want everybody to stop dying they're
dying Russians and ukrainians I wanted
to stop dying for people in Ukraine it
must have been chilling to watch they
now know they can't count on Donald
Trump as an ally
and the reaction of this audience and
recent polling suggests he could well be
back on his way to the White House
Martha counter Sky News